spreading fallout from that stunning and
stunning is a word supreme court leak of
a draft opinion that suggests that roe v
wade is set to be overturned now these
are the headlines today showing how the
shock waves are reverberating
reverberating she's trying to say across
the nation with alarm on one side of the
abortion rights debate and criticism big
criticism on the other it has also
galvanized politicians on both sides of
the aisle ed o'keefe is at the white
house with more on this story ed good
morning to you
good morning gail here at the white
house president biden believes that if
this draft opinion stands it's going to
put other rights at risk and he says
it's now up to lawmakers to protect
abortion rights even the possibility
that roe versus wade's going to be
overturned has poured millions of
dollars into the campaigns of democrats
and their related causes scrambling
already contentious midterm elections
[Applause]
protesters took to the streets across
the country
and against the supreme court's draft
opinion to overturn roe versus wade
abortion is murder and i feel that way
period women will be trying to shuttle
back and forth from different states to
try to get their rights fulfilled we are
not going back
on tuesday night vice president harris
joined the fight how dare they tell a
woman what she can do and cannot do with
her own body
it's really quite a radical decision
earlier in the day president biden
blasted the draft opinion warning the
decision could threaten other rights
like same-sex marriage it would mean
that
every other decision
related to the notion of privacy
is thrown into question republicans were
outraged as well not about the decision
but about the leak this is the most
egregious breach of trust
at the supreme court that has ever
happened most republicans even avoided
commenting on the implications of the
opinion if this is the first time we've
had somebody on the inside
try to attack the institution with
narrow house and senate majorities
democrats have failed so far to enact
federal abortion rights into law ever
since texas passed a restrictive
abortion law last year while a bill
passed the house in the fall it was
blocked this year in the senate but
party leaders say they'll try again it
is time to wake up and democrats also
see political opportunity just minutes
after the news leaked some campaigns
started emailing and texting supporters
for money
act blue which funnels donations to
democratic candidates and causes has
processed at least 10 million dollars in
donations and counting since monday
night
but republicans doubt abortion rights
will be a top issue by november i think
this election is going to be decided
based on the quality of the economy
and
safety
so a little more on the potential
politics of this biden advisor tells cbs
news they believe if the ruling
ultimately stands this is going to help
mobilize what they call harder to engage
voters maybe younger people or those
that only show up every four years to
vote for president believing they'll now
understand that a real fundamental right
is at risk the advisor cited polling
that cbs news and other outlets have
done that shows a majority of americans
want to sustain abortion rights and they
argue that quote every single swing race
will be impacted by this decision nate
ed thank you